welcome
to this new topic on kubernetes here in
which we are going to talk about what
exactly is in common it is and how we
can make use of that
so uh kubernetes uh you know what
exactly is the purpose of using
kubernetes
benefits architecture and ultimately at
last we will be having a short demo on
the kubernetes here
now kuber it is what exactly is a
kubernetes tool all about here
now uh we talked about kubernetes as in
we consider it as an acquisition tool
like
a container management tool there where
we can manage multiple containers
uh both on physical infrastructures or
onto the cloud infrastructure there
now what happens that uh we can pretty
much deploy the docker containers
with the help of docker on the docker
engine or docker
uh host also there but there are some
limitations
uh like we cannot have on high ability
we cannot have a auto failover we don't
have the auto scaling
lot of features uh does not exist in
case of the
standalone docker so in order to keep in
mind in order to go ahead with that so
we require us
another tool which is known as
kubernetes now
kubernetes is known as the acquisition
tool
for the fact that this can manage and
handle multiple containers
so it's not like only one or two
containers which we are talking about
it's
like a plenty of number of containers we
want to do here
so pretty much one single cluster of
kubernetes can help you to manage like
different projects and the different
containers as such here
so this is something which is really
important because it's a very uh
easy to utilized it's an open source
tool which is available there and
it helps you to deploy uh the containers
docker containers across different
environments
um the failovers is there the auto
scaling a lot of additional features
like the modern application features
which you want which you require you can
actually utilize over here in case of
kubernetes
so kubernetes is something which is very
uh important and helpful for us
because of the fact that it helps us to
define a lot of implementations
uh what exactly is uh you know let's
talk about the analogy over here
right now uh assume that you have a
house of five uh
rooms like there is a house which is
having like all together five rooms over
there
there
is a constraint of that how many rooms
uh will be available there
now um you want to rent out like two
rooms uh
through the air bnb like uh that's the
platform which you want to use so you
want to go ahead with that part
you want to proceed further with that
two extra rooms like you don't want to
use it
now for this one you've got like two
choices what are those choices here
first you either go for an particular ad
and
you monitor it yourself like you do it
for yourself over there or you can hire
a person to do that particular activity
for you
uh of course like if you feel like you
can manage the things and you have got
enough time for that you can go for the
manage like the direct management for
that
but if you don't have the capability and
you don't have the time for that and you
don't have the enough resources
then of course you have to hire a person
which will be taking care of this
activity for you
over here now if
you choose any particular agent now
agent responsibility would be like
hire the employees which will uh meet
your requirements like
cleaning the rooms maintaining the rooms
because it's not only about having the
tenants
it's also about like keeping or
maintaining the rooms also because that
should be cleaned down over the period
of time and
a lot of management work or maintenance
work required over there
so that's a complete work which will be
taken care by the agent and he's not
going to do
all the work as such he may be hired
some more employees for you to do that
particular activity
but yes he's going to manage he's going
to be a single point of contact for
keeping off
all these things so he will be taking
care of all the records like how many
tenants came in how much cost is there
but it's the
uh you know total revenue so all that
things will be done or will be taken
care by the agent
so agent is going to take care of all
those things as such so that we don't
fail any kind of issues
and uh you know it will be readily
available for the owner like owner can
just reach out to the agent and get all
these required details
right so what is the relationship of
kubernetes over here in this case so
let's talk about that let's talk about
the relationship because we talk about
this real time scenario
so how exactly kubernetes fits in over
here
so the facility which you get from the
agent
that you know which can employ other
components or
which can help you to uh do all the work
for you
and you don't have to take care of
anything that's where the communities
comes in
so kubernetes will be deploying like
different applications there
and you don't have to do any kind of
management work as such there
so kubernetes is something which is
there in in place of this agent
which takes care of all the requirements
of small or big requirements as a chair
whether it's the maintenance of the node
whether it's a deployment of the
application so into independent
applications or activity will be
performed by the kubernetes cm
so one of the different benefits which
we get with the kubernetes here
so let's talk about the different
benefits now the different benefits
which you get over here is the better
infrastructure
so better infrastructure is definitely
the something which we are trying to
look forward over here uh better
management through
uh modularity so that's another benefit
which we get over here
the deployment rollbacks uh the rollouts
the scaling auto scaling manual scaling
all these things are quite easy
in case of kubernetes so kubernetes give
provides all these additional benefits
where we don't have to rely on the
things manually pretty much with the
help of a good amount of automation we
will be able to get all these
uh issues are resolved as such over here
so that's the biggest benefit which we
get with the help of these components as
such here
and then uh it will help us to lay down
the uh foundation of the cloud native
applications here so that's also
something uh which we will be using and
uh where we will be seeing like how
the overall implementations can be
really achieved over here in this case
so these are some couple of benefits
which we uh really get so that we can
see that how the implementations and the
setups can be
already achieved over here so all these
things are really helps us to see like
how the overall implementations like uh
these are the
high level of benefits which we get our
foresee over here in this one
so that we will be able to understand
like yes these are the different
set of benefits which we pretty much get
over here in this case
of kubernetes so if you summarize the
most important benefit of the kubernetes
is like
in a particular sequence it will help
you to deploy your application
right and uh it's not like one-on-one
application getting deployed
multiple uh systems multiple machines
you can actually deploy your
applications and it can
already function properly over there so
you don't have to manage the things you
can
pretty much with the help of the
kubernetes manage all these uh
containers these uh management of
containers can be
quite easy with this one now let's talk
about the architecture of kubernetes
here so kubernetes architecture is all
about like various components
now we got a scheduler over here which
is going to manage like most of the
scheduling part
uh we got the controllers uh which is
the internal components of the
cooperatives which manages like all the
controls
should be up and running and it's
responsible for performing the internal
activity
and etcd is in kind of a data store here
now every application requires some back
end to store the information
so adcd is something which acts like a
back end for the kubernetes
and then of course we got the api server
which is available there the api server
is something which
we are going to use which acts like a
main component so
all the components of the kubernetes
whether it's a master or node is
directly integrated with the api server
so the communication between the master
and the slave or the node machines are
actually
there with the help of api server only
and then on the node machines you got
like kubelet because this is a high
level environment of the kubernetes here
where we got like multiple nodes on
which the kubernetes parts or the
containers are getting deployed
so you can see like kubelet coupe proxy
part these are the different components
which is available there on the node
machines
on the another environment on the other
server here so combine these became
a complete architecture over here the
master slave architecture is what we are
getting over here in this one
right so let's talk about these
components one by one first we will talk
about the
architecture components of the master
here so scheduler
is something which is uh responsible for
assigning the parts to the not ca
now i say like let's deploy the part of
the
specific jenkins now when i do that so
in that case what will happen that
my request will be sending on to
different node machines the different
node machines which is available will be
taking up that request
and then it's going to say that okay
let's go ahead let's execute that and
proceed with that particular
component so these are the different
components which is available
which is giving us the way like how the
executions and the setup
needs to be performed so again
we are using a terminology called part
so uh in case of docker we call it as
docker container but in case of
the uh kubernetes we call it as in uh
parts over here so that's what we are
trying to use
so pause is what we are trying to uh
deploy as such as the
standalone unit which we deploy in case
of kubernetes cluster so that's what we
call it as in part cm
right now uh this schedule is something
which will assign
the task that on which a particular
machine we are going to deploy our
application our particular component
here
so that's what we are trying to deploy
so that we will be able to see like how
the application will be
uh really deployed over here and on
which node it will be deployed so all
that decision factor is something which
will be taken care by the co-operators
here so that's where the
communities takes up the decision that
how to deploy the application
and uh the assigning of these uh
resources will also be depending on the
number of resources
uh like what kind of resources available
there so what kind of a memory and
other details which is being available
so that also is being
taken care in regards so while doing the
deployment all these things will be
taken care here
so uh next thing is the controllers now
there are different controllers which is
available there
so we got like a node controller we got
like our replication controller we have
also got like endpoints controller
and then the service account and the
token controllers over here
so these are the different controllers
which is available which we are using
so that we will be able to see like how
these equations will be done
and how we are going to use these
different different components as they
so when we talk about these controllers
these are the components which is
you know really responsible for keeping
your overall kubernetes cluster
up and running so if these uh any of
these controllers
uh is not uh working fine as expected
so that is where the real problems will
start coming up over there
so you need to have the specific
you need to have the overall uh system
which needs to be implemented over here
so controllers are very important for
your
latest cluster because without this one
your whole node will be
not working as expected right so node
controller is something which is
responsible for monitoring all the nodes
which is available there in the master
and uh this
complete cluster here this multi-node
cluster so we will be using the
node controller to manage or to monitor
the different node machines
here uh the replication controller it
uh helps you to do the replications for
instance like
we have the replication mechanism that
if something happens to the parts if the
parts gets corrupted or deleted
then a replicated uh part will be
immediately created over there
so keeping in mind we can actually go
ahead with that setup so we can see like
okay
if we are facing the issues like this if
anything goes down
immediately we will be able to have a
replica and this replica will be
again back there to make sure that the
application is always up and running and
we will be able to get
the desired output there so that's the
replication controller which we
utilize here then we got the endpoints
controller which is used to uh merge
these services and parts so
um the request from the services will be
then sent out to the
specific parts there and then the
connectivity will be established so
for that particular part for that
connectivity is where we will be using
the endpoint controller here
and then the service account and token
controller so these are something which
is being used
so that the api access or tokens can be
utilized there so this is something
which is being used for the api
communications so that you will be able
to see like how the execution needs to
be done like how the
setup and modification should be
performed here so when we talk about
like all these uh
different controllers so these are
something which can really help us to
see like how
the overall executions should be done
and should be achieved here
so these are the different controllers
and uh these controllers are making sure
like the kubernetes cluster is always
up and running and any of this
controller if it's not
working as expected or there is any kind
of issue so
uh the kubernetes cluster will not be
stable and it will be unstable over here
so
these controllers will should always be
up and running in order to have the
stable environment now next one is the
etcd component now etcd component is
considered as a data store for your
kubernetes cluster like this is
something which is being used
as a data store here which means like
when you working with the
kubernetes so it requires some kind of a
database
so for that part what we do is like we
basically use the
etcd and this adcd is something which
will
have the information related to the
parts and deployments everything stored
there
so when you are working with the the uh
particular kubernetes cluster so
it does not support any kind of mysql or
that kind of heavy duty
databases so these kind of uh databases
like atcd
will be utilized by the kubernetes here
for storing all the information and the
desired values here
and uh it's something which is going to
store all the data
like what is the configurations what is
the deployment what is the
services details what is the part
information so all that information we
will be able
to get with the help of this atcd here
and all the uh port forwarding rules and
those activities are also getting stored
in these data stores
so it's kind of a complete database
which is there for the kubernetes and
anything which is getting stored is
connecting uh
stored as such in case of the etcd here
so etcd is very important to consider
like how we are going with the
component implementation here then we
got the api server now eba server is
acting like a packet here
now when we talk about api server so
it's uh having a kind of a component
called google hyphen api server here
so it's a main component which does most
of the processing there
so all the internal processing will be
taken care by the api server and this
api server is directly connected with
all the components so all the requests
will be sent to these components there
so once the uh specific configuration is
done once the setup is done so you will
be able to see like how the processing
and the
output will be processed here so this
api server is something which
definitely helps us to see like how the
executions is going on how the
scheduling of the things should be done
so it's a main component like it's a
it's a core component which take cares
of most of the component most of the
implementation here so it's a very
important component of a kubernetes
cluster
so now let's talk about the specific api
server components here like how exactly
it works on now when we talk about the
node machine so here we got like three
components google it
google proxy and pod here now kubelet is
a kind of a
process which is there which is uh being
deployed on the local machine on each
and every node machine you will have the
google it
and this kubelet will be interacting
with the api server so from there the
communication will be happening like how
the execution
should be done and we will be getting
the output here
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more and then we have got like
coop proxy
now when we talk about google proxy it's
responsible for the network rules
like all the redirection of the network
uh request is
something which we do with the help of
group proxy so coop proxy is something
which will be
uh doing the uh network redirections of
the request like how
uh when we put up a request on a
specific node how it internally goes on
to the specific survey so all that uh
redirection of the request to the the
traffic redirection to a specific part
is being taken care by the help of the
co proxy here
and then parts is there like which is
available like how we can use the parts
on a particular cluster
so uh each and every node machines may
have like
you know specific kind of uh setup over
here so
we can see that our automations like we
can deploy these parts as such on the
clusters and we can see like how the
deployments will be done
so part is the actual uh container where
the application will be deployed and
it's something which can
uh be restarted distributed across
different different old machines
so depending on the kubernetes cluster
it will be deployed like across
different uh machines or servers as such
right so let's go for a demo uh to see
like how we can run some couple of
kubernetes command group city commands
there and see like how these
occasions needs to be done try to get
some resources which is being deployed
on the kubernetes here so let's connect
to accommodates cluster
so first let's see like what are the
different node machines which is
available there
so coop ctl get node a command is
something which will help us to
see our node over here right now we have
got only one node which is the master
node here
but if you feel like you want to get a
little bit more additional information
about this node
so you can run like ctl describe
node and the node here so no name is
what you can provide over here and then
you can get a series of information
like uh what are the series of
information you will get over here is
like
um what is the name of the node here
what is the role here it's master
and uh you know you can get some
particular conditions
um you get the ipads the internal live
areas over here
uh what is the os image all these
information is what you're trying to get
over here in this one
so that we will be able to see like how
the execution needs to be done over here
in this case
now uh when we are trying to perform the
automations like when we are trying to
do the
uh setup over here so this is where like
all the configuration is
is being done so this is the cpu here
uh this is the particular memory and uh
regarding that all the information will
be available here so what is the
architecture
all these components will be available
and will be
performed over here now this is the node
information
when we run like ctl getport so we get
the
uh custom parts which we deployed over
here
but we also have certain parts deployed
so for that
i have to go for all name spaces like
name spaces is a kind of a
space which is available in kubernetes
now kuber hyphen system is an internal
name
space so uh but when you run the coup ct
you'll get parts so you get uh
the all custom deployed parts which you
deploy but the coop city get parts
and uh the coop system name space here
is actually going to show you like what
are the different companies which is
available there
so all the companies which we talked
about like api server the controller the
proxy
uh proxy in the sense the services proxy
the scheduler
then the etcd all those components will
be available over here
so you will see those components and if
you talk about these services so
services is also something which is
available there
so when you deploy your custom services
you deploy your customer
application of the parts here you will
get your own services available here
so in this one you will be able to see
like okay these are the couple of
services which is available there
where we want to redirect our traffic to
a specific part here
and if you feel like you want to uh do a
describe on a specific part so you need
to say like okay
the uh describe uh kucitil describe part
and a part name over here so part name
you can see like
let's say like you want to go for the
api server here
you go for that and then you need to put
the namespace here
so hyphen m is something which is there
for the name space and i know
now that it's running on the coop hyphen
system namespace here
and the moment you do this one you will
be able to get all the informations like
all the different
details will be available here to you
like you can get the complete
information like what is the
uh particular conference running here
what is the ip address here
what is the continuous you are running
here everything will be available here
so this completely gives you the
insights like how the execution of the
kubernetes cluster is going on there
and you can pretty much go ahead you can
deploy a couple of containers and a
couple of
parts you can deploy and you can get
your custom applications deployed
so this is a mechanism like how you can
pretty much go ahead and you can manage
some couple of services and some couple
of deployments
as such on the kubernetes cluster so
let's go back for the main content there
right so uh these are the different
commands now uh
we also got a command called uh coupe
ctl
get parts iphone hyphen
all name spaces
iphone or white which will give you a
kind of wider information like how many
ips is there or how which node it's
running if multiple nodes are there so
you will get the nodes information
so this is an uh one any additional
command which is there in place of the
coop city parts
where you get an add-on informations
like these are the additional
informations which we are talking about
so these are the different components or
different commands which is available
there which depending on our requirement
you can play and you can see like how
the deployments can be done here
right so this is what we have in the
case of kubernetes where we talk about
like how we can make use of kubernetes
and what are the different benefits we
get with the help of kubernetes here
so that's it for this guys thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here